you rich rich now man i'm not that rich
man i mean i got 200 on my neck
four actually it's 400 300 100. um you
got a thousand in your butt
i'll say that's true
[Music]
funniest [ __ ] ever uh i texted [ __ ]
uh
since chandler's coming out here i was
gonna maybe try and just meet up with
him and his brother later or something
yeah
because i've been trying to meet his
brother for a while uh-huh uh
and i texted bobby i said i don't know
if you're a um
fight fan michael chandler's going to be
out here and he goes i thought hooker
won
bobby lisa
yeah channel coming on food truck yeah
that'd be good man
he was just out here too was he for what
he was out here probably a month and a
half ago too much
right when he signed with ufc he flew
out here where his first interview
and he was like it's poor area he was
like it's pourier gaity or connor it's
only three people i'm fighting and when
hooker got out so i went yeah you
thought wrong
dog ufc don't play like that it's wild
bro dude i'm wondering they got that
transgender fighter too now
which one what'd they say about it you
saw it no transgender fighter in the ufc
a new one you're not talking about the
old one failing fox are you uh
no one of them died i think in the
oh you're overdosed or something no
you're thinking of uh what's her name
the big
wwe chick is that who it is yeah
if you're transgender who do you think
you should have to fight man or woman
are you a man transitioned to a woman
because we got that that man physique
the man bones you gotta fight other men
or we create just a straight up this is
her
league for transgender people damn
looks like the rock's dead we should
actually definitely not use sound for
this
yeah a big old heifer oh man that would
be
she got that stepdaddy energy too she
got that angry stepdad
she does nyla rose there she is
that looks like that big girl beating
your ass and now oh yeah that's
bbc big gene bro put me out
did you didn't you uh [ __ ] up your neck
dude i hurt my neck cheering for [ __ ]
fourier to fight
oh i got your cash oh you do yeah you
want it right yeah i'll take it in
person yeah yeah
let me get that buy a thousand dollars
worth of [ __ ] uh
i just got a new shirt that's what you
got yeah
where's that from uh it's 25 i'm not
sure
i got these chains too baby how much
your chain costs you think
how much mine different game daddy yo
really different game you got that new
money
i bet i got a better deal than you 400
yeah i bet mine's real though i bet you
i can shower with mine
[Laughter]
i wouldn't treat my gold like that these
are 400. once 300 is 100.
i gotta make sure i don't give you too
much man i can't have you taking the
extra and
sniffing it
good point there i am right there bro
you give me too much money bro that's me
getting my shots the other day on my
neck dude
that's you getting that vaccination oh i
said put one of them right into my they
give me a shot glass of toradol
you look like you're selling merch at a
covet [ __ ] testing facility yeah
boy the diamond is a boy's best friend
baby i'll tell you that
do you buy that man buy a grand worth of
hot sauce doug
i'm gonna buy something i just bought
somebody somehow i've been buying hot
sauce i got enough i feel like you got
ownership i got a name
you've been pushing that [ __ ] on this
show like a [ __ ]
i wonder how much he sold after the
fight you think he sold a lot i don't
think so
he tweeted the other day sauce boss so i
think it's doing all right
can you name anybody else with a i know
stevo has a hot sauce
but the name of it doesn't make me want
to put it on anything it's called like
hot sauce for your [ __ ] or something
like that that's like stupid
yeah it's too much that's absolutely
[ __ ] but um
tj uh dylan shaw has one no the guy who
we had on
miller yeah he he has uh his own hot
sauce yeah evidently he's really
passionate about it
evidently it's vodka infused he's the
only person he's the only person that
came on
this past weekend with a with a bloody
mary at a freaking 11 15 in the morning
he's such a savage
oh this is gonna be huge for dustin hot
ones
not once and then he puts his then he
puts his hot sauce on it
yeah good for him is he uh
but is it through zoom i'm not trying to
see though
yeah uh it's through zuma also could
they've gotten a different picture
this one looks like he [ __ ] he just
got out of prison
yeah hot ones and some guy looks like i
get out of prison has a whole different
vibe to it i feel like
hot ones yeah the diamond on hot ones
that [ __ ] sucks via zoom though yeah
they shouldn't have been zoom but the
good thing is he'll be able to sneak his
own sauce in
so that's pretty dope it's good sauce
man i like it it doesn't make my butt
hurt or nothing
sauce boss so i hope it's going well for
him
dude i'll tell you what's not going well
out there is all these different
you know a lot of people have different
pronouns these days i'm him
but um dude i hit on this girl right
and in nashville l.a this is in l.a okay
you got to watch your you got to watch
your steps here in l.a man you don't
know what it is these days
dude she said what did she say she goes
um do you like
men and i was like no i mean i like men
they're cool
i don't like mittens anymore
[Laughter]
women
i said this he tried he gave it a good
old cause try
that dude made an effort man but yeah
hit on that she goes oh because i
identify as a man she's like would you
ever hook up with a guy and i'm like no
and then i didn't know what to do
anymore yeah because you don't want to
offend her right she's like i
identify as him he and it was just hot
[ __ ] yeah i doubt that playboy
yeah you mean a hot dude
no dude hey is this you coming out right
now
bro no dude first of all if i was gay
dude i would be shocked
not me especially after this story we
had a bar
he's like hey bro you want a bear you're
like damn you're sexy
bro you look like a [ __ ] janitor
at wade robson's cabbage patch
unbelievable first of all you guys don't
understand that's a one piece
oh it's a jumper dog let me get for the
fans though
bro white man yeah white men can't jump
or i'll tell you that
bro dude you can [ __ ] pain in that
[ __ ] do you show up to pain
look at that sauce daddy damn bro
ain't the sauce daddy i'm the sauce
daddy there man i'm challenged right
there
challenge for the challenge for the hot
sauce king
oh yeah so you're hitting on this
transgender and dude
would you hook up with a man and i'm
like no you know maybe
yeah i mean i'd hook up with a man like
if we were like you know maybe it was
like a big storm or something but i'm
hooking up with a man in [ __ ] regular
weather yeah if you get
snowed in you might if i get snowed in
and all the women freeze to death
you know and the guy keeps promising
he's a woman you know or eventually
wants to be one
no and he has to promise he is but
anyway
so now is this kind of strange i didn't
know what to say to her say to him say
to her
it was her [ __ ] look i looked i
looked for the adam's apple turnover i
looked for all of it
big hands oh no she didn't have any of
it she was a woman there was no doubt
there was no doubt no there's doubt
because my pronouns
are him his or the [ __ ] it is
they do your thick ass your [ __ ]
pronoun my pronouns just stick
your friend is more than one us dude
i'll tell you what i've never been hit
on a chick and never thought to myself
well i wonder what
her pronouns are which she's pretty
clear she forced the issue
were you at like uh where where are we
at at the coffee place
and it was so uncommon you know what to
do so i just been down to tie my shoe
dude and i had sandals on
so i kept just practicing on the sandal
like you do when you're [ __ ]
three-year-old you know so how'd you
leave it
she left man he left him and his
[ __ ] hot chicks him and the three hot
chicks he was with all left
they got their hummer and drove off
on that h3
did she or he have big tits yeah she had
two big chairs yeah
daddy was looking he was i like it well
that's what i'm saying you couldn't have
just
there's a lot of bad science out there
for people trying to get the surgery and
stuff like that these doctors are good
though i'll give you that man
those these dogs especially in l.a
they'll get you you ever heard the story
of brian
when he was uh shooting um which story
well a good story okay the story that
matches this
was this in the la times no this one
there it might be after i tell the story
he was shooting uh the hangover two in
thailand or something
and then the the boys went out you know
there's a lot of ladyboys out there
and he said he said he was in a club and
it's all dark
and he's like making out he goes dude
this jig was so hot make out mate get
out
and he goes then she took my hand and
just put it down there and he goes i
felt
a big root nut i go damn what'd you do
dude he goes i didn't want to finish i
just kept making up
wrote that look i respect good dude
hashtag good dude
bro why didn't they write that in the
article that they with the accusations
yeah man that right there is like what
you don't do that if you're if you're if
you're some kind of like deviant you
know
yeah diamonds are forever
say diamonds are a girl's best brain
i don't say that i don't say that either
but i am saying blue now.com the
original online jeweler
for high-income adults wow ballas get
your diamonds
and the thing about diamonds is man
diamonds used to be underground so you
couldn't even get them
but those days have changed and now a
diamond is i mean you could
you know now you have access to diamonds
and who can help you blue nile.com ooh
you ain't lying man and also valentine's
day is coming up
maybe it's your girl or man's birthday
yeah i'm not in the men's anymore
man women women
what i'm telling you is this right here
brother is that a good
a lot of young men ain't gonna do any
better than the dime that you with
and that's honest you know and that's
true for all of us men
you know we keep thinking no this is
gonna happen i might go to france and
backpack you ain't doing [ __ ] little
henry all right
so get your girl that rock bro you know
what i'm saying finger
finger her up and get that rock forward
yeah i don't say finger up though
but you can go to blue now dot com make
the moment special man blue now dot com
king sting listeners get 50 off 500
right this is a podcast exclusive it's
only good through valentine's day it
includes engagement
all right go to use the code kats that's
code
cats plus every order is insured ship
free arrives in discreet little package
so it's not gonna give it away man yeah
it might say beef on the outside you
know or textile
might say kimchi on the outside yeah
your girl's like i ain't opening this
and then you bam
boom diamond freaking what's up that
land rock dog
oh yeah good they got good diamonds too
and no surprise you can give you a
beautiful diamond
shop stress free and find your forever
piece go to bluenile.com today mandatory
talking points in yellow
look the truth is if you haven't
freaking uh taking care of your crotch
with a razor you probably never are
gonna
yeah so let's probably just skip past
this ad because if you just enjoy being
hairy like a russian
then this ain't for you but if you're
trying to get a girl or a man's
and you're trying to get shaved down
like a dolphin
ain't the men's nmo go to manscape.com
man manscape we got you
covered the lawnmower 3.0 trimmer is the
best hygiene tool
ever there's a flashlight line you can
shave your junk in the dark your girl
put something sharp near your dick bruh
these are the people to help you do that
all right fam
straight up dog we tired of you running
around with that wild dick bro with that
deer dick
with that badger dick with that
porcupine peter dog
tighten your [ __ ] up or [ __ ] don't
dog but you know about manscape there's
no [ __ ]
yeah man get 20 off and free shipping by
going to manscape.com
kingston praise god they also have a lot
of other amazing hygiene products
just all the men's i'm not in the men's
anymore twerps off and free shipping by
going to make sure your dick up get your
dick right go to manscape.com
king in a sting baby they also have a
ton of other amazing men hygiene product
on the website disposable mats
everything get your pubes in and out the
door in motion
get that winner dick right uh i wasn't
gonna play this one today it was
gonna be for tomorrow but uh or next
week this is one of our transgender
listeners has a
impromptu debate all right let's hit
this tg up
hey getting this thing this is taylor
from massachusetts
and i had a debate club for you today um
if you can't tell by my sultry voice
i'm a transgender woman um i've been on
hormone replacement therapy
for about five years now as a result
i've been able to grow my own pair of
homemade hitters
now my question for you today is do you
prefer natural breasts
or do you think that some big old fake
chest pillows would be a better option
i've always considered having a breast
augmentation but i've actually kind of
grown to like my boobs so
any commentary or feedback would be
welcome and gang gang d-cups
yeah go d-cub carson got them tits
what's his name
this is from lance what's his name
taylor
taylor taylor that then that's kind of
uh yeah could go either way there
great name dude taylor for sure dude
this time cool man taylor doug
this dude tailored up his crotch brother
you know what i'm saying he's going into
that [ __ ] he's that haberdasher baby
dude i'm never mad at the upgrade of the
tits
or the chasticles as you call it oh yeah
now a lot of people stole that term for
you
they did and i know who a lot of people
are seth rogen did yeah you know
phoebe heave yes jessica started with
theo vaughn
all right speaking of c cups seth rogen
has them too
but i think a nice upgrade always a fan
yeah especially it's well done now if
they're too high and they're set up in
your chin
no it's 2 on 21 baby drop them down oh
that's crazy when people have like the
when people's real long in the rib and
they get those top and then like
i think the doctor looks like he tries
to balance him on the rib cage like on
the top of the rib cage yeah you gotta
do it right man doctors there's like a
couple of [ __ ] just gargoyles out
there yeah like sometimes they're higher
than the person's shoulders
looking over them yeah like a mound yeah
no
i like those chest hitters man look i'm
a fan look
five years of transin it looks like it's
coming in pretty decent man i'll say
that man you look like a beautiful young
man bruh praise god
and um
tits are hard to grow too you i i would
assume he or she's on estrogen
so that's gonna make your tits pop a
little bit yeah that's a lot of hard
work milk you gotta soak your front
chest in this [ __ ] soy milk
soak in almond milk dog yeah that'll do
it too oh dude i think yeah i think
you're doing good with them tits man and
i think uh
keep growing them though don't stop yeah
don't stop get
big yeah it's a marathon grow them
[ __ ] out
wear a [ __ ] thong on them dog yeah
get them [ __ ]
[ __ ]
maybe sign up for an mma class yeah yeah
yeah dude and in three years we'll be
talking about you
bro taking over you'll be back you'll be
fighting chef chinko
nick are you a fan of the big tits uh
natural is more uh
more my speed uh i've only been with one
woman who had fake breasts it was porn
star mary carey
uh wow nick dropping [ __ ] wow all
right
she died right yeah oh no she's still
around she she can i can i see her
doubt it and she she's would she be uh
labeled as a milf these days her
brother's jason what's his name that mma
guy isn't he
uh i didn't know that oh
good for you nicholas she came on the
adam carrillo show and i shot my shot
and how'd you shoot a shot with a porn
star i literally just went up and
basically just started a conversation
she took it from there she like asked
about
my dick in the first conversation yeah
oh yeah
damn good for you typical man trick
[Laughter]
walking up and starting a conversation
dude with a sexist pig and was it a good
time nick
it was a great time but the the boobs
were like
comically comically giant and like you
feel like the skin
move away from like the actual it was
that's age
yeah yeah that's age man i've always
said it man as the women get older it
feel like the body's kind of stuck in
like a a
loose bag you know a wet sack yeah no
one likes the them wrinkly titties
sometimes the skin hangs so low that
gets all wrinkly like a throat
dude i met a girl one time i was this
band let me go on the road with him
as a singer as a damn backup singer
right damn you were hustling man
i was not doing well i was such a bad
singer
and they were such a bad bad picture
going
[Laughter]
no it was the song that let me sing was
called lonesome dove and it was a
country song
in lonesome yeah it was bad
bro you were hustling that was awesome
dude
i think it's a [ __ ] coin dog what a
comeback story man
look at you now bro back to back with
the rio
grande yeah it was brother it's a real
comeback story
so uh there was one other song that let
me sing on too
it was like a widespread pain there was
like maybe three songs on the town one
of them was that ben
uh not ben harper who was the guy before
ben harper
bob marley no the first mixed guy that
really set it off
lenny kravitz
[Music]
you're talking about that genre though
did he have dreads uh
i can't remember i never saw him i just
heard the music and did they fire you or
did you quit
well i'm not sure what happened but i do
remember that one time we were in uh
somewhere in south carolina and i had to
we did we'd done a show
you know and afterwards we're [ __ ]
backstage or whatever not even backstage
still in the bar was just at a bar
so we're just again especially it was so
bad you just walked right off the front
of the stage and nobody was there so
we were front stage we were literally
front stage and
uh this uh lady came up to me dude this
freaking crazy lady said she was a
teacher school teacher or something
and then anyway we ended up ended up
making out and
her breasts felt like [ __ ] diapers man
like you could mold them and they would
stay
yeah like like the like the clay at
spencer's or some [ __ ]
or sharper image you squeeze it and just
stays like that
yeah it was just like that memory foam
literally yeah she had memory foam tips
yeah she literally had them [ __ ] that
t
you know
so i was like i've molded one into a
heisman you know i can just do a
different [ __ ] with them
put a smiley face oh man
i'm older when i wrote the wnba sucks
with it
but and how much did they pay you can't
be much
i think they just let me come with them
i think maybe 150. you're just going for
the experience
oh yeah it was bad man stage time
because i was going to do comedy but
then we tried the comedy it didn't work
and so then they're like well dude just
get up here and sing with us
oh man you went through the ringers
brother
yeah i've been through it all maybe like
whenever i have some [ __ ] happen on the
road always takes theo first like hey
man this ever happened to you he's like
man shut the [ __ ] up i was singing in a
strip club one time
all right man i thought dan hooker won
that fight
uh this gentleman's wondering your
guys's thoughts on uh the super bowl
what up what up fellas your boy ryan
from las vegas just want to start off by
saying i'm a huge fan of the show
and i got a debate club for you or it
could be a king interesting at either
one
but i just binge listened to every
single episode of king and the sting and
by the way it was super cool to see you
guys evolve
and see you guys transform from episode
one to now but with binge listening i
noticed
i think it was episode 62 you guys when
tom brady was talking about
leaving the patriots right you guys
joked around and said that i think there
was talks about him going to the
chargers but you guys joked around and
said tom brady was gonna leave
and i think it was brendan made a joke
about gronkowski going
and then antonio brown going and then
they're making it to the super bowl well
look
it's happened they're all there all
three of them went there and now they're
all going to the super bowl so what do
you guys think what are your thoughts on
on tom brady making to another super
bowl do you think they can pull it off
uh let me know what you guys think i
would love to hear your uh hear your
opinions
thanks a lot guys gang gang buzz buzz
thanks for powering through all the
episodes my man
wow therapist after
uh i i want to see tom brady win
i'm rooting for tom brady i mean
obviously the cool things to do is patch
my homes and the chiefs
everybody's on their nuts but i'm
looking for that old gunslinger
yeah i'm brady man antonio brown gets a
[ __ ]
trophy that'd be dope antonio brown
seems like a real [ __ ] but uh
i think it would be i think it could be
really
you know there's something that's only
three oh no i think look they definitely
want to get a lot of people to bet on
tampa
bay i mean i think there's a good chance
that kansas city could win by 12 points
you know they could blow him out yeah i
mean i think tom brady could get out
there and lose it in the last drive it
seems like it could be that kind of game
i'm trying to think away you can go
double or nothing with that with you
guys
i'm pretty happy with my money and i
already donated to the damn [ __ ]
[ __ ] thing you know sorry i'm just angry
that
i keep [ __ ] donating money to this
thing
so but yeah the good fight foundation
you can find it on
dustin's website but um
yeah uh dude i think i think it's
interesting to be able to cheer for a
great quarterback now that he's
separated from the team that everybody
thought was like it becomes like
they thought belichick was like the
secret sauce you realize he ain't
shipping an [ __ ]
yeah well he ain't [ __ ] without this
dude but yeah it's definitely brady has
a lot to do with it yeah hell yeah
everything to do with it
but belichick also he [ __ ] picked uh
cam newton you know what i'm saying like
that was just horrible they had nothing
to do
you know like they had nobody else yeah
it must have been a front off oh yeah
what are you doing for the are you doing
anything for super bowl are you going to
be in l.a you mean that i'll probably be
in
nashville all right i'm super michael
chandler invited me over you are having
one if i'm here i'll come
all right i've been for 40 years your
bowl party haven't i'm sure yeah every
year
so but yeah look man i don't know what
is your prediction
i'll bet the over of i think 56 so i'll
bet the over
and i'm hoping the tampa bay buccaneers
win but it's tough man basketball homes
so
[ __ ] good kill they're so good
tyree kill is insane the cheetah his
three legs dude someone said his dick
has an ankle on it yeah
five toes yeah he's a beast that's
unfair
you know what i'm saying check that
dude's [ __ ] dick
somebody said he got a massage on his
dick the other day i'm sure man
that because he [ __ ] sprained it
doing a turn
that's insane i'm going for tampa but
it's gonna be a tough one somebody said
he had [ __ ]
turf toe in the end of his dick okay
he had to get his dick wrapped yeah he
had tinnitus in his penis
i heard his dick have cte
from bouncing around while he's running
around oh dude somebody said his dick
was in a neck brace from [ __ ]
whiplash from one of the [ __ ] or as
big as a visor
[Laughter]
why i don't know yeah you're right
uh the return uh here comes the complete
opposite of tyre
kill this is the return of clown my
hound
these people did great they sent in
videos oh yeah yeah bring these little
[ __ ]
before we go i want to say look to the
transgender guy keep going man get as
far as you can
buy a shield get a [ __ ] dick get a
titty do it all
yeah and then take some of that fat and
put in your ass yeah yeah
yeah dude that push for that cookie get
that brazilian butt lift
build that tip jay in the tray make sure
you know if he was gonna pick you up at
a coffee shop
look it up they're from mass
she's from matches he's from she's from
massachusetts dunkin donuts
country so that's oh yeah there we go
dude but uh yeah
cool coffee right scorpio that could be
theo's next wife dog you know who knows
who the girl i'll tell uh
taylor i'll tell taylor if you go all
the way bro you go full throttle
you'll go on a date get them nuts get
d-nutted do all of that
nutty though bro first of all mail them
in if you get them taken off
you know what i'm saying and we'll do
something we'll do we'll put them in the
studio we'll
bronze and put around brennan's neck
[Laughter]
we'll put a bell in him that way we'll
know when he's coming in
i'm nuts he'll put you in the king
single hall of fame you
rip that dick off man here comes brendan
yeah yeah dude you'll be in the culture
corner for sure bro
you got to bring that voice up an octave
though too dude yeah you do a little
deep right now
yeah you sound too much like chappelle
yeah you're coming in a little dark in
the old
throat let's see what this guy is
what up bromosexuals big fan of the show
it's dave from columbia south carolina
dave first off today is my 33rd birthday
shout out chappelle know you just had
your 34th
also theo been working on that gnhc
tell me what you think yeah that's a
gender neutral haircut for all you fake
fans
let's go i gotta clown my hound for you
today
check out my dog tug and what we call mr
bo dangles
gang gang dangle bow dangle
this is my big homie tug
let's say it's hard for him to walk
she's an american bulldog
bull mastiff mix weighing in at
about 20 bucks 30. big boy 13 years old
that's a polar bear bro but tug he's got
a
he's got this little what they call a
skin tag
oh hanging right next to his
wiener
[Music]
oh
[Laughter]
that looks like it'd be easy just to
snip it dude bro that's a chicharrones
[Laughter]
skin tags all over me has that weird
growth out of his dick
he looks like an extra in the wire
oh you got a monkey you gotta tighten
that puff up
yeah man go send that pup to see taylor
okay
yeah send that pup to see taylor doc's
working with taylor send this pup there
man
yeah taylor you gotta start a frickin a
petting clinic bro you gotta re-up this
pup bro
man he got this disgusting god he got
that nut hanging out bro we got that out
nut
get that little purse package out the
front man oh if you're listening to this
on audio you got to come to the video
this
is it's disgusting what's the worst talk
is it disgusting it's crazy bro pull it
off dog yeah it looks like you just
snipping he'd be all right
i like how he goes don't worry it's he's
fine with it oh yeah
would you be fine with that growth off
your dick bro yeah you don't have a guy
hook him up can you sleep in your bed
that thing open your leg
you know it's a beautiful animal though
dude i think obviously ah man that
thing's ugly oh come on man you got a
shape
you have that weird nut extra nut
hanging off i'll say what i do like
though he's an american bulldog dude you
know what i'm saying
yeah you know what i'm saying you
sucking off the statue of liberty's tit
bro and i like that dude you know what
i'm saying keep that us a [ __ ] egg
look at this little pound historic hound
damn huh
this one comes from uh dave from
massachusetts this is
ziggy he's a four-year-old boston
terrier that's the same guy that has
sent it in sorry
oh no that was tug did i say the other
one was
no there's no dog named dave uh dave
sent this in
this dog is ziggy the other dog was tug
or mr bulge angles yeah
they need to put mr bojangles down let's
be real let's call it like we see it man
yeah that look that little bitty piece
of them is already dead
no this is ziggy he's a four-year-old
boston terrier from massachusetts
recently a new father
attached is his tinder profile picture
for any [ __ ] trying to get pregnant
hell yeah
and we've got his latest conception
video and a picture of him and his
daughter from said conception
so this is a good-looking hound man i
grew up with a boston tear named spud oh
there you go
oh oh that's my move
oh yeah look at theo at the coffee shop
and then
here's oh don't let the kid get that
close while they're having sex bro
that's insane
is that sex this is what they dogs get
stuck together after sex a lot
why because the the dick swell is inside
there and before it goes down
and so this is like the aftermath uh but
then this
is what this is another reason why
taylor needs to open up that shop as you
were saying theo what are you what is
this
what so my girlfriend just told me about
this in this video came in but yeah
it's like a real problem with the dick
gets entangled it happens all the time
to docs oh wow but yeah he's in there
oh why is it why you let that kid go by
while these dogs are
[ __ ] in the living room the kids are
like what's wrong with the dog
man what's wrong with ziggy daddy he
touched one of them on the back
bro that dog was not down dude look go
real slow that dog
was not down he did not touch him
actually
go real slow when he walks by
that dog knocked down he's clean that
dog was knocked down dude that guy's the
worst free
safety in the world bro this is like the
minnesota miracle and then
there's that black guy from new orleans
dude
why are the why is a kid out there when
the dogs are having sex
that dog [ __ ] man oh what are you
talking about
oh and he got a dick on him oh my god
hound city baby and then here's his uh
new little child
oh damn those things are cute man
oh look how much he aged after having a
kid yeah
my god he looks 70 years old now he had
to do it to you man
it's like when they show the president
eight years later they're all grayed out
cute hounds though man that haven't got
a dick on him
i didn't look you can't miss it man huh
you can't miss if you don't look at it
you can
all right oh there you go there it is
what a legend man i'm not looking
at it first team all dick but yeah those
were some uh great clown my hounds
great submissions keep sending in those
videos wow beautiful animal and this is
a french bulldog no this isn't
that's a boston terrier yeah yeah boston
terrier
boss tears are weird though because
their little tail stick up in the air
so when you get near them they're just
their black [ __ ] are just always out
oh it's too much yeah it's too much uh
so this came in
another return segment race my case this
came in from justin
he did an incredible job uh found three
cases and really did it up
gang let's see this man thank you justin
how you doing king and esteem crew my
name is judge justin
and i'm bringing you guys one of my
favorite segments you do on the show
called race my case let's get into it
okay jeff one thing being a judge i come
across a lot of these idiots so
bear with me here's one of them a nasty
hotel housekeeper took a woman's panties
from her room
and left his number in exchange a group
of female guests staying at the
riverside hotel casino
out of local nevada told police that
they returned to their room after a
soccer tournament
only to find that their panties were
missing and a note
was there instead what the notes say
though the note read
text me if you want your panties back oh
that's a black guy
the gentleman also demanded new photos
in the process hell yeah so i guess the
ladies ended up texting him
and uh he started asking for the nudes
what a guy looks like in the process a
pair of wireless earbuds was also taken
it's unfortunate you can't trust
housekeepers i know all of them aren't
like that but
jesus said that
your foreign gang gang judge judge
oh yeah that's awesome man
i'm gonna tag him up on this justin is
his name that's just justin dude
listen your honor you gotta do like that
you're right well your honor this is a
pretty clear case here uh
you present your case and i'll present
your case because
any janitor or house cleaner that's
going to steal some wireless earbuds and
jam while cleaning
definitely herb and ish i'm gonna go
with black and then ask for news from
these big old
bbws yeah
but i look look uh look your honor i
uh i would like to say that
anybody that's yeah i think if
somebody's taking the uh
it's in nevada so it's so dicey too
because it's a weird nevada
ever anything to be in nevada indian and
a casino
so that leans heavily asian out of the
gate um
i'm gonna say to indian uh asian or
black and then also to leave the note
though
take the wireless headphones like i
would just say it straight up holla at
me boo
you know from outside in the hole yeah
you're right holla boo
yeah you got your panties in the back
yeah so i'm gonna go white on this
actually i'm gonna go white i just see
it being
even though you don't see a lot they
said it was a man right
yeah who are men who are men
that are room cleaners
black men you think i've ever seen one
sometimes you see i feel like an
african guy sometimes i'll see an
ethiopian
yes yes uh sometimes you'll see
a me i'm mexican i can't
last night i can't i can't remember that
somebody's need to wipe out the room
cleaner
never you know i just don't think that i
have so i'm gonna go also then i'm gonna
go
i'm gonna go because the note is the
part that's throwing me off you know
note
casino in the weird part of nevada it
has native american written although
but i'm gonna stick with black okay i'll
take this one for you then i'll roll
native american i'm saying somebody just
you know um you know i think the note
and and the dream catcher gives gives
away too yeah the dreamcast could give
it away
but yeah i'm going to go native american
give it away the note and the
[ __ ] rain stick also the bad
negotiations native americans had some
bad negotiations
you know that's historic yeah and so i
think the bad negotiation is in hey
i i'll trade look if you want your
panties back
to holler at me send nudes right then
the sin nudes was the dumb part it was
like that's the black guy i think
but that was the horrible part of the
negotiation also here's my other thing i
would like to know what these women look
like if there's some bbw some big
butt women big beautiful women white
women
they're at a soccer tournament what do
you got nick
he was native american
hey not only is he native american but
he's cross-eyed
it might not be cross-eyed dude they
have a lot of different talents
yeah well that one's cockeyed and has a
forehead on them
that's also a native american megamind a
lot of native americans
can see like four different directions
you idiot yeah this one can't though you
know
maybe uh sun dudes was his native
american
just a signature he wasn't even asking
for dirty picks
good call nick uh we got a second one
judge justin coming in
yeah that was a good one he's got three
great great cases so this is number two
that one was good man we were on it we
kind
[Laughter]
26 year old was pulled over for speeding
when the cop approached his window
they could smell a strong odor of
marijuana coming from the vehicle
that's why after police did a short
search of the man's car
in person they found a bunch of
different drugs on this guy
he didn't miss he had it all and they
also found a large amount of money
so well when they took him into the jail
they did an inventory check
turned over all the drugs and now
they're looking for the money they
couldn't find the money
that's when they did a short another
short search of the person and
everything that was going on
only to find that there was a 20 bill
sticking out of his ass like one of
those dancers at magic city
i guess the dude had a little tail
feather of a 20
bill sticking out of his butt cheeks and
that caused officers to have to do an
unfortunate lengthy search of this man's
ass
and uh turns out that he's he stashed
almost eleven hundred dollars up there
gang gang judge judge that's my case
boys help me find this one now
we need to get this guy uh we need to
get him some help
first of all look your honor uh your
honor jo
justin um what i want to say is that
obviously this man is doing his best out
there
i'm tired of the drug dealers being
called the cr like the bad guys they're
at least doing business
you know what i'm saying if you're a
drug user man that's really the [ __ ]
that's the part that you're not making
any money and you're just using drugs
yeah at least a drug dealer is doing
business yep
you know it's kind of messed up i
understand if he's dealing drugs and if
it's against the law take the drugs
i don't necessarily think it's fair to
take the money though especially if when
he put made the sacrifice and put in his
butt
yeah people look dude i have a rule
where i'm from if something's in your
butt
it's yours yeah me too man shout out to
aurora that's how we roll
praise god cops know that yeah i'm gonna
go with this no
so there needs to be more cop respect
but on the racial uh
rules bro yeah that's a street rules bro
money hanging out my house that's
mine that's my money dog yeah i'm going
white you're going white on this one a
lot of drugs
like different kind of drugs smell of
marijuana but the smell of marijuana
thing is because every time a black guy
voted there's
there's there's marijuana and they're
like they're always shocked like what do
you
like like they didn't know you can't see
the smoke comes out of the car
i'd like to know what kind of car it was
and i'd like to know what city it was in
you know what i'm going to go mexican on
this man i just i'm going to i'm taking
a flyer on it i'm going back
white he's a black guy
wow that man put all that money in his
booty hole
is it draymond green too or am i racist
wait is that chappelle
dude that almost does look like
chappelle if he did very similar to
chappelle if he didn't really get things
together
nope if chappelle was still drinking
that's him
man i kind of feel bad the guy i feel
like you know i feel like you really
need that money
well dealing the drugs isn't helpful to
nothing man you know but
someone's gonna do it though yeah
somebody's gonna let all the cartel get
the money damn i should have guessed
black i was on the black and you [ __ ]
talked me out of it
i said white ah i'm old for two uh
yeah so we no tie breaker needed do we
want to save it for for the next time
let's save it i think yeah save it this
guy's good though check theo where'd he
put that thousand dollars
judge justin all right uh we'll move on
to
some debate clubs dj khaled
what's good what's good theo what's good
brendan what's up playboy shout out
i mean from brooklyn feel me um this is
a debate club question but before that
when i get some of my akas out there you
know what i mean
john daly in the beautiful brown
stallion aka girth over worth
aka sikkim on your favorite thickem aka
[ __ ]
[ __ ] all that [ __ ] um i always saw joe
rogan
as the oprah that i mean first man
holding it down you feel me
amen and the bait club man joe
[ __ ] renegade youtube taking
over rogan
or [ __ ] oprah billy named billy
goat
winfrey feel me um choose wisely y'all
special shout out to y'all man keep
doing your thing
girth girl birth birth or whatever the
[ __ ]
yeah you didn't know what to say gang
man but i like that that's fine yep i
like that you didn't even know what to
say you kept on saying yeah you stuck
with it bro
yeah that's nice that's nice that you
you know just weren't afraid to just put
do whatever and put it out there man
respect
that's a great question man that's a
good question
so he's saying oprah or rogan yeah i
think like most influential
kind of well for the bros can you name
another person's more influence did he
say man now or do you say overall
he just said he he just said joe rogan
or oprah
i'm gonna say for influential i'm gonna
say
joe rogan me too because
i mean you know how dude i could throw a
[ __ ] nickel right now and hit 45
[ __ ] dudes
you know white belts who are [ __ ] you
know grilling
up and on trt yeah grilling ostrich neck
on the [ __ ] yeah
full of alpha brain yeah on their back
in their backyard
alpha brain dog you know what i'm saying
like i could [ __ ] i could hit a
nickel
i could hit 50 of those so inspirational
like
and think how many people joe's put on
now oprah put on you know
dr phil came from him but that's really
it that's about it
oprah probably could have put a lot more
people on she's a selfish [ __ ]
well i don't and i don't know what she's
like me neither
but she's definitely more of the
hollywood side of things
you know i think she's a great
interviewer i think she has a great
voice but oprah couldn't interview like
elon musk
like joseph rogan no rogan have elon
musk on then joey diaz then my dumbass
you know what i'm saying
yeah and they're all entertaining yeah
yeah i think it's and also think if
people go on that show it's everything
can be edited you know
and also on rogan's you're [ __ ] oh you
say something bad and you'd be like hey
man can you take this out
no yeah he doesn't edit anything the
other thing is is
think about all the people rogan's put
on their careers
think about it everybody in here pretty
much
everybody in here think about it sagura
used to open from joey diaz
ian edwards and we can go through all
them
what do you say duncan trump duncan i
mean there's so many [ __ ] people
though also but although the people that
he's put on other people also like
i mean a lot of comedians have also been
working their career like you know i'm
not going to
he gave him a platform right give him a
platform oh no don't i'm not saying that
they wouldn't have made it without him
because the the talent's undeniable
like you coming on firing the kid you
the your talent
whether you came on firing the kid or
you came on rogan or you came on
you know schultz is brilliant idiots
your talent would have came through no
matter what
we're just i was just fortunate to have
you a phone call away
right on firing the kid but you're also
welcome you know
yeah well thank you for having me too no
i'm just kidding no i'm serious though
dude thank you guys for having me bro i
wouldn't be podcasting today if you guys
didn't have me on there yeah
you took over our studio you know that's
true man you know
you know what you moved in you know what
popped up on my story the other day on
youtube you know
there's an algorithm our first episode
ever together and
at fox oh yeah i was old and you and i
didn't know each other i'm like yo
i've heard good nothing but good things
about you i gotta go yeah
you bought some of it and you were
pushing like your album
oh the hamster bones yeah yeah that's a
good album dog
and you're like you're like i'm at fish
and chips stand up this week four
shows i was like god damn theo is a
different dude
you rich rich now man i'm not that rich
man i mean i got 200 on my neck
four actually it's 400 300 100. um you
got a thousand in your butt
i'll say that's true i got a thousand in
my dog
people like how rich are you i'm gonna
make the cops search the next time i get
pulled over i'm just literally gonna
bend over
and that's when you [ __ ] are pretty
gay i think yeah if you just they don't
even try to search you and you get out
and just bend over
and have money in your butt
uh but for you to say happy easter
that's the worst bro
uh i would definitely say rogan yeah and
i think you're also asking two men's
like if he's asking women's it might be
different you know
even women's now though of course our
fans 1910.
yeah but a lot of men um now think of
this rogan doesn't need it but think if
rogan was like yo
i'm starting a podcast network so anyone
who's going to start a podcast before
everyone
and their mom had a podcast he created a
network and had all those people under
his branch
dog he'd be making more money than
spotify pays him
yeah what do you mean he doesn't move
like that though yeah he's like i'm not
trying to own anything you guys do your
own thing
and also once you start doing it all
becomes more work too
i think it was smart yeah he played it i
mean he
he knows what he's doing just staying
with what he's good at
and he just loves what he does i mean he
said he he just should hear his plans
for uh
austin really i can't put it out there
like that because he asked me not to
talk about it but dog
when he tells you like oh [ __ ] damn game
changer
well it's good for us because we'll have
a spot to go to in austin you know it's
gonna be a hub now for comedy
you have la austin nashville and uh new
york
that's like the hubs that cap city was
getting a little bit ratchet
yeah um dude but uh what else i thinking
yeah and then oprah though like oprah
will put you i don't know
joe kind of turned oprah was kind of
before rogan though
in a weird way right but she was way
before
but her popularity even because then it
was like ellen kind of came
after oprah remember because it used to
be she used to be on at like three
o'clock
my aunt used to have it on every day
after school totally and she had a book
club any book club she suggested just
blew the [ __ ] up kind of like rogan you
know right suggests
you know how him and ana got started the
owner of on it aubry came on at the time
there was no on it
and he came on to push fleshlights and
so they pushed fleshlights and it just
sold out like a [ __ ]
then aubry's like yo man we should do
this alpha brain these nootropics
together
and so rogan pushed that and they
literally couldn't fulfill the orders
fast enough damn
and then now it's on it on it you know
so like [ __ ]
alpha brain when joey sells it bro
tip top magoo look man a lot of people
out there right now
struggling you know um
i mean hell if you're watching this
podcast you're probably not doing that
well
let's be real honest and if you're
making it you're definitely not doing
that well yeah so you've got some help
man i could have been on the discovery
channel
yep but what i'm telling you is get some
help man and there's no better time to
get help
we all have a friend that needs help
brendan and so
every time and every now and then you
see the man your friend and he out in
the garbage or something and he's doing
something maybe he got rabies or maybe
he's a raccoon
yeah don't talk to the raccoon though
yeah no don't talk about the license
professional that's why i need better
help man it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help it's professional counseling
looking at me swan
yeah quit look at me swan better help is
committed
to get you guys right man it's more
affordable than traditional offline
counseling
financial aid is also available better
help once you start living a happier
life
today in fact they're killing it man
this podcast is sponsored by better
health let me hang it over dude you
don't understand it bro
you can't get help if you need help dawg
what i'm saying is visit betterhelp.com
k-e-t-s that's
b-e-t-t-e-r better h-e-l-p
help and join the over one million
people who have taken charge of their
lives
all right i'm talking about you with the
mental help of an experienced
professional
uh this podcast is sponsored by better
help and king of the sting listeners get
10 off their first month
betterhelp.com cats brain up super
specio man
you know the only way i can do this
podcast or any podcast with the help of
that kratom hitter you talking about all
natural hitters you're on kratom still
all the time really
non-stop i didn't know that i thought
you guys got tested for that whenever
you see me i'm on kratom
damn i swear by you wanted to nick no
i've never had it
chin snorts it but the thing is is uh
you gotta trust who you're getting your
kratom from just the wild west out there
really yeah you never know where you're
going to get it that's why i just bought
some dojo coin
oh no no no no that's why you gotta
trust super speciosa
they're the one in the game you can
trust their creatum son
all right and they're offering you guys
20 off and you gotta trust your kratom
that's where super specio comes in for
you guys
go to get super leaf dot com slash kats
that's get
super l e a f dot com slash cats
enter the promo code cats for 20 off and
that's getsuperleaf.com
cats from code cats uh here's uh
punky johnson what's up brandon what's
up theo
quinn here from kc you already know
super bowl champs holding it down the
best athlete in the world patrick
[ __ ] my homes
new orleans saints denver broncos ain't
going to win
[ __ ] any time that's fair
nothing soon but [ __ ] man thanks for all
the positivity
a couple days ago man i tested positive
for uh covert 19.
uh it's been kind of a stretch you know
rough stretch here last couple days but
watching you guys man really helps me
man list my spirits man
i'm pushing through bro i'm gonna be all
right but uh [ __ ] i got a debate club
for you
when you were in elementary school dodge
ball or kickball
oh let's hear it gang
you ever played crazy kickball where you
kick the ball and you can go to first or
third and then you can just stay on the
base and you pile up and you grab
hands to get to the next base ooh crazy
kickball
it's good oh fantastic damn we didn't
have we had some more bootleg
[ __ ] like that we had looking for gold
was a game we played just looking for
gold outside
um dude we had um
red rover was always dodgeball depended
on who came back to school that day like
some days we'd have a kid at school that
was 30 years old
and i was like this dude ain't supposed
to be here but his mama dropped him off
that day or something and
you know he didn't he wasn't working or
something you're playing dodgeball with
the grown man yeah so now you're like
[ __ ]
dave's gonna win yeah yeah yeah mr
allen's gonna win
you know and so sometimes that that was
the only thing about dodgeball was there
was no
check and balances system you know that
red rover red rover sent brendan right
over oh
i come [ __ ] bailing through that lane
doug yeah
my little fat ass just bailing through
him [ __ ] those really good days
running you can't do that anymore
running backwards dude you can't do it
anymore
vernon played basketball he was a power
backward
power back red rover red rover was the
original wedge breaker on kickoffs doug
oh yeah totally that's a good call dude
uh kickball was
fun though kickball was fun and
you didn't have to have all that extra
equipment you have to have the gloves in
the middle just
the ball dog and the baseball field dude
we had one kid on our
baseball team we were 11. he got out
there he couldn't afford a glove and he
got out there with a
kitchen mitt hell yeah and he was good
too yeah a little like kind of mixed guy
but yeah he was good man um i'll say
kickball dog and they you can't do
dodgeball schools anymore either because
they said they'd pick on kids
that's the game dog get the fat kid in
the corner you light his ass up first
dude sometimes he's surprising catching
everybody come running in yeah
damn he couldn't you get hit he just
we're waiting
and then when you got hit you're walking
you get hit in the face
i'm out stupid yeah that was the worst
bro when people would light somebody up
the worst one got hit in the face in
front of your crush
oh your face be all hot and red like
that even hurt
and then your crush is like i'm a hymn
they pretend to tie your sandal harder
what time i sandle thanks gene dude i'll
tell you this i saw it rob tonight i got
to go hang out rob schneider the other
day backstage oh yeah how was that it's
pretty cool man
where were we at nashville india
he did 14 she's doing 14 shows god damn
they're all sold out wednesday to
tuesday yeah
god dang that sound out live [ __ ] doug
i mean it's just a lot of time to be
spending in a town too
i mean yeah it's incredible it's a lot
of work you can do it oh yeah he was
going at man it was uh
he let me do a guest set one night but
it was just cool to um
see i've never talked to him before so
he started just just telling all these
stories like his mom was filipino so he
started
telling all these stories about uh like
their family stuff i guess
but then he would go into impersonations
of different characters have you had him
on the podcast
uh-uh i might have him honest i'd love
to have one sometime but it was just
interesting
i've never met him but he's fun on uh he
came out finding the kid years ago did
he really
if you can get him to talk about it live
that's where the sweetness is at
yeah but when he wants to come on talk
about yoga and [ __ ] san francisco
tell us about the glory days of saturday
night live dog give us the go dude those
were the glory days
dude him chris rock david spade sandler
farley it's all just different now like
even nobody does
characters anymore you know what you
know what i'm saying like nobody does
characters anymore never
like they just don't have it anymore
damn he was only on there for five years
he's the trail davis of [ __ ] shining
alive
i forgot about all the movies i didn't
even know about all the movies he's done
when i really thought about it he's in
so many good dude deuce bigelow i never
seen it
god what a movie it's spanish for big
[ __ ] you know that
deuce big lois i didn't know that i
don't speak spanish my family does
though
i knew that should we move on some
relationship advice yeah obviously this
is duncan
this is a hot tub time machine duncan yo
it's the king of the states the
we cannot say that about this guy it's
gonna break his heart no he knows his
teeth are [ __ ] up he's been he's been
through some struggles i think he might
know
no he knows he knows his teeth you know
hard to see this video when you have
[ __ ] up teeth and
and the first thing somebody says you
have [ __ ] up teeth dude he knows
nobody wants to get bit by him
i'll tell you what one thing he can't do
is bite pizza perfectly round like i can
dude
yeah if you look at my [ __ ] ig store
you'll see really we'll put the picture
in dude
perfectly round bite i didn't even
notice that someone commented on him
chompers on you no he he bites it looks
like a goddamn great white took a bite
out of your [ __ ] cheeks
yes you got serial killer t somebody
said look at that
oh you got them richard ramirez teeth
okay i like you i love your teeth man i
think you can do whatever you want with
them yeah i think it makes you unique
what up guys it's your boy dave from
pittsburgh um and i need some
relationship advice
uh i've been with my girl for about 10
years now
um and when we met we both love to party
like most people
oh yeah well i had some good times
but i ended up with an addiction um and
so did she
uh by the grace of god she's got three
years clean and i'm coming up on a year
let's go one year longer
anyway let's go analyze the question my
girlfriend has a degree in psychology
she loves helping people currently she's
a counselor at a methadone clinic
the problem i have with that is the
stress she's under
every single day i'm sure you can
imagine what these people are putting in
through telling her you know she comes
home every day
just suck dry i mean just
yep i'll emotion for you where i think
she hates it
not that she hates it but she hates it
how do i tell her i think that's the
wrong career path i don't want to come
off
mean like i don't support her but i
think she should choose a different
field maybe something where she can
still help but
not necessarily in that way and then we
got to hear sign off
uh gang gang nod nod
oh yeah that heroine that's that heroine
that heroin dream state baby
hell yeah dude i went with a bunny of
mine to the uh
to the jazz festival uh in new orleans a
few years back and he was
just aged out the whole time and he
[ __ ] literally slept
like seven bands and got [ __ ] sun
poisoning
drugs are a [ __ ] man but it was
unbelievable
what were you doing the whole time just
rejoining yourself
yeah totally hey man you want a bear
yeah and then finally i guess he just
wants to rest you know
and we didn't have any things and some
people thankfully some people some
[ __ ] hippies that built some big
kites and would lean those against them
to
block the sun that some was tearing his
ass up but that was four bands in dude
that was already after
elton john and uh oh and they're long
and sugar ray had done a return
dude you lucky it wasn't a grateful dead
concert
yeah that boy would have been jerky
he would have been just dead
he would have been looking great he
would have been ungrateful we've been
having conversations with jerry garcia
bro yeah and he was out there uh
but look man i dude yeah i think it's
hard to have a job in that sort of
industry especially these days man
people just get so zapped out
but also if if she's getting money and
that's like her thing she wants to help
people how you gonna tell her no
yeah and also i don't know if you have a
job either david i don't mean to bring
that up but
you don't
you don't want to look a grocery horse
in the mouth you know what i'm saying
so you don't make a video
video on a tuesday afternoon and have a
job bro
he could be an artist yeah you're right
he's probably a painter
but what i'm saying is look man uh
congratulations on coming up on the year
congratulations on your girls three
years man
yeah it's big time man it's big of her
to try and give back look i think she'll
know when it's time to quit i don't know
if it's
you know it's i don't know if it's up to
him yeah i don't know if it's affecting
you but
it's nice that you shared it with us to
just try and even get it off your chest
a little bit yeah and can you
can you bite a piece of pizza and send
it in
man you're all [ __ ] cold man
i like that guy man what well tell him
that
i just did
but yeah bro y'all gonna be fine man
but don't look a freaking grocery horse
in the mouth baby dog
don't look a grocery horse in the mouth
baby you don't want to look a produce
pony
in the yapper you know what i'm saying
dog you gotta [ __ ] make sure
you got that cereal and milk yeah i'm
gonna make sure it shits together
yeah oh finally a woman dude what
happened to that girl from australia
that we're bringing in remember
[Laughter]
we'll hit her up oh that titty hit her
from miami you remember that
her yep she had great teeth too yeah you
mentioned what happened with that hottie
taylor that
video in the beginning hey what
dude the first hits ever so i was on a
big guy dude nice to go sleep at his
house and look at him
yeah you get it we'll
bro dude you're the one who [ __ ] is
wearing
[ __ ] sexy custodian gear and it's not
even halloween you [ __ ]
forgot okay will you turn this woman on
before we're both gay
hey guys i have a king at our standard
for you so i know you've talked about
scars on men before but you've never
talked about scars on females
i'm a canine trainer former state police
canine trooper it's a whole other story
but um my last rescue that i took in for
an aggressive case was a dog argentino
125 pounds
um almost mauled me to death um to fight
him off it was a really bad case so he
got me
really bad there you can't see it
because i have makeup on
but i'll send you the before and afters
but you can also see
the severes that i have joe rogan
probably inspired this
and i also have a metal plate in my
illness so my question to you is
are scars okay on girls or should i be
like
super insecure granted i'm going to get
this full sleeve tattooed so hopefully
you won't be able to see it but
that's my question don't cover that's
the map of your life girl that's what
tattoos and scars are a map of your life
man
yeah i think look if you're gonna get a
plate in your head i would go
i'd go two i'd go you know four or five
pounds something at least when you're
walking or running it's going to put a
little bit of uh
tone up your body yeah you know and not
as a crazy way but just
you know at least use your disadvantages
to your advantages
um and also i think it's amazing i'd be
so scared
if something i was trying to care about
just just freaking mauled me like that
um she has more pictures of the wounds
do you want to uh i mean brendan might
want to look away
oh you're disgusting brendan i knew you
were
looks like a shark got her
god damn probably a hard pass for the
dogs that first one i showed you is the
worst
yeah that one that it looks like you
know looks like
describe it describe it to me i don't
know it looks like a shark took a bite
out of her arm
and then it looks like richard how big
of a shark like what do you mean ah
probably like a baby great white it
looks like a tiger
little baby tiger shark got a hold of
around like how long does it start to be
like this or like that
about a foot long oh damn that little
deal
tiger you only have so much jaw space on
a foot long shark yeah you're right
and then it looks like uh on the side of
your stitches or not each thing on the
first oh yeah
oh yeah stitches and probably skin graft
and skin
uh muscle graft and then on the face it
looked like richard ramirez didn't
finish the job
oh good description
she's pretty hot though brendan
that was me like a compliment yeah but
she's trying to get better you're
and that's the dog god damn i think it
looks like a [ __ ] white gargoyle is
she all
take it down yeah take the no this this
is uh her after like
oh yeah she's a good looking beautiful
lady saw the video of her
she looked beautiful i think look oh oh
[ __ ] turn it off that's good
deal though to see you need to see what
the repercussions are owning a [ __ ]
dog well you're thinking about it
yeah but i'm gonna get a safe dog i'll
get a handicap i'll get that first dog
with that [ __ ] extra
no yeah with that extra bubble gum nut
yeah with that freaking nut that extra
freaking bag that goiter
uh hold on what was she asking though
can get her sting it chicks with
scars king it yeah king
king big king she's got scars yeah
you're good
now unless you like that girl swimming
uh surfing hawaiian got your [ __ ]
whole arm ripped off but some people are
into that
yeah i could date somebody that has one
arm i could date somebody that has two
arms or whatever
you did dude one arm nope
ain't no dude don't trick me with the
one arm
trying to trick me yeah this is bethany
the whole movie about her too tiger
shark she's beautiful
look at her son too look at him with
both arms
look at him flex on his mind with both
arms is she pregnant there
yeah looks like it wow wow good for her
dude every chick is pregnant in hawaii
really i think so yeah
theo touch of the downs vaughn yeah
brendan td
slobby shob this is downtown travis
brown
from indiana quick uh king understing it
for you
more than one pillow when you sleep in
your bed oh yeah all times
i don't really see what the big hype is
two pillars
wake up with a stiff neck i just can't
roll with it
uh let me know culture corner what's
happening
nick chen how you doing
gang gang buzz
buzz damn get it out daddy first of all
i want to say travis brown you're doing
way better than he is
[Laughter]
i want to say that kind of thing bro
congrats on that man you're doing way
better than
ever i won the marathon yeah let's say
that he was his friend i won the mayor
he may have won a round but he won the
marathon
um yeah but i'm just glad he got this
video in before he blew up his camper
outside of the [ __ ]
uh hooters in downtown nashville uh i'm
joking brother you seem like a nice guy
um you sleep with one pillow i sleep
look
i am i need three pillows man and i
still am getting ivs and [ __ ]
chiropractor every day so
uh i i sleep with three pillows i go one
with the leg
one under my neck and one in my arms
actually two
daddy yeah and i'll put perfume on the
one on my arms so it's like a woman but
it's not
you put a little
i like the long body pillow i hugged
that i hugged that thing
up snuggled that thing got one behind
the head another one wrapped around like
a big old girl
i love it you get that big i love it
only brendan his body pillow [ __ ]
weighs 70 pounds
dude it's a [ __ ] great black shark
um dude now what about this though when
you're sleeping do you uh
do you face away from your wife do you
face towards your wife
yeah yeah sometimes it's the only time
you get to be away from him i feel like
and
close to him at the same time how do you
sleep with your girl nick
yeah i turn away she hates it it's like
you gotta get a little cuddle time in
but i i turn over i also don't like
face and sleeping because then i feel
like i'm i'm breathing their
oxygen and breathing they're all their
bad ideas are coming out at night and
you're breathing them in
yeah i don't like it yeah i feel that
uh we got this guy already kind of
what's this burn victim
oh my god bro what are you
talking about this is a great young man
no you're right man
do you want to hear the options huh
let's go let's ride with this guy from
obviously from is this your buddy got
left out in the sun on heroin
no his name's sean and that's not him
and sorry sean but i didn't say your
last name but also
anybody who knows you is gonna know it's
you bro
and i love you and i'm just guessing
you're not talking about sean o'malley
he was just talking about wanting to try
heroin a clip went viral
really yeah that's awesome well that boy
gave me some trouble with that
was he yeah he was holding his he was
holding his child on his podcast yeah
and that's good and then they and then
they went hard at megan anderson which i
i don't support that who's that the
woman yeah
who's that his wife no she's a female
ufc fighter in case she's playing amanda
she's a badass wow australian girl
really talented
man i like that dutch girl who was so
good and then she came out all frenetic
last time and got smoked
two fights ago by that uh there was like
a young black woman i think
oh yeah you're talking about uh maria
agapova versus shanna dobson
she like gassed herself out she's like
she's got like uh gauged ears and stuff
and she's like yeah she's always like
this
she's spunky yeah she does too many
punches towards the camera in the
beginning yeah
it's like just do it once yeah
this guy looks insane
what's up thesaurus and bernard
i gotta sting it or king it for you
that korean kicker kimchi
what do you say is that a redhead
stinging her king at king and sting it
bang bang guys guys dude is this the
doctor from the girl that got bit by the
shark what is that guy eating
oh look man first of all you seem like a
great guy
i want to say that man out the gate you
got that hat you got that body those
tits oh that's what is that
oh that's a shaky like yeah
i love that girl man i can't believe i
did the kimchi without
chin here though yeah he wouldn't have
added anything
[Laughter]
last episode he said three words he
doesn't talk on any of my shows
i think something's going on i think
he's thinking about killing me
but if he killed you it would be that
would be all i mean it'd be
unfortunate but it would be
unprecedented yeah it wouldn't be good
but it'd be crazy think about it like
the first like you know ever since like
david spade got attacked by his
by his uh that's right assistant that's
right he
tied him up and tased him and [ __ ] we'd
all be characters in a movie for sure oh
yeah
called making a podcast
who would play you you think in the
movie pride taylor
or joyful tone
almost maybe joey fat
enjoy fat tone yeah joey's going oh yeah
broadway oh yeah wait like an
off-broadway joyful tone
way off bro we're talking cincinnati
yeah yeah i'm talking about cleveland
broadway wow
dude wow yeah that's my dad
uh julian's [ __ ] awesome dude i could
even look like him on the left
i look how hairy his arms are it's rough
that his last name actually spells fat
one yeah oh
that's tough that's a rock yeah justin
timberlake
justin timberlake said i gotta get away
from these [ __ ] [ __ ]
dude justin like always looks exhausted
doesn't he yeah he's dancing all the
time
um so then what i would say is um
jesus christ i would say king it man
what is this guy talking about
uh kimchi not my thing hearts thing bro
yeah what is it cabbage and hot sauce
yeah
it's like an asian cabbage and hot sauce
and look it's easy to say that in
america where we have you know they have
a lot of food here
you know america it's like you can you
can't have food we'll give you food you
can't have house we'll give you you know
there's no everybody gets a [ __ ] can
of [ __ ] you know
bean and wieners dogs so um
i think that yeah in other places you
got to make what to whatever
whatever's left you got to make
something good a lot of times they use
spicy
so you go to india bro they'll say like
you should have this beef spice and it's
just like a
broth and it's like it tastes like beef
kind of but it's like not like they
don't even have any meat you know so you
just eat in different
you know they put they write the word
beef on it it's just something yeah
i don't know what you're talking about
but i'm saying it someplace this [ __ ]
started in [ __ ] korea dawg
yeah i don't [ __ ] with that at all i i
mean chin's ball deep in it
yeah chin up uh come what's called
kimchi kimchi and uh sardines for lunch
uh oh
yeah and it smells like [ __ ] he eats
sardines yeah all every day
that was my secret santa gift from him
that's right really he brought sardines
my brother eats sardines and it always
made me think that we weren't even
brothers
don't make sense disgusting when they
open a little can they're all in there
it's like a little
it looks like one of those grave sites
from like world war one that's a
concentration camp for [ __ ] sardines
dude you open it up and they're all just
then you eat them
all of it eyes ears
disgusting [ __ ] hard stinging on
kimchi
yeah but i dig ginger hard sting on the
holocaust hearts on kimchi facts
but it's definitely yeah it's like but
look here's the thing though i think
it's just an acquired taste like a lot
of you know
a lot of japanese people don't like
mustard you know it's just
that's the thing it's like some some
things they just don't like in some
places
yeah you know a lot of uh russians don't
like popcorn did you know that
why they just don't it's not it's too
soft
it's just like hard [ __ ] bro popcorn's
for [ __ ]
it really is russians want that hard
[ __ ] sausage in their mouths
you know them brats
then german brats yes
calm now okay nick wow
uh do you guys eat it your girlfriend's
uh
i'll try like when you go to korean
barbecue they have like all the stuff in
the beginning and kimchi is one of them
and i'll
usually have some like eel and [ __ ] nick
if it's there i'll like try it but like
i'm pretty much
i'll eat anything if people put it in
front of me but i'll stay in my comfort
zone if i'm left to choose for myself
wisconsin bro stay in your lane
yeah cheese milk potatoes i might be
right but the eight man a lot of the
asians they'll do
like i'm sucking off a catfish bro
i saw a girl eat like a decent look good
looking
girl eating a talon
of something out of a bag on a train and
it smelled so bad
yeah i just couldn't even believe
someone was allowed to eat it like
literally had you hot it was dug i've
seen she's [ __ ] eating it had
a skin and it didn't even clean the
fingernails on it dog i
i ordered wings from wing stop for the
crew
and chin ate the bones yeah like the ear
though but like you know how you eat a
wing eat the bone throat chin eats
sucks the [ __ ] mirror out the middle
then chews on the bone
dude yeah a lot of chinese you know
they're really
they're kind of they're the african
americans of the eastern hemisphere yeah
that's fair
would you guys try the geoduck if we got
some in here
yeah i detailed that thing come on man
why do y'all do this every time
nothing busts what are y'all doing
is this still alive when you're eating
it
oh yeah hell yeah girl slap that thing
around we're missing our experts i'm not
sure
no but didn't even add anything last
time did we learn anything like that
no they've never tried it either hey man
yeah uh
you know i feel like
that's all i got that's all i got happy
black history month if you're black if
you're not
glad you're black brother good to be
black
stay black [ __ ] suck us uh what else you
got man
you got anything coming up you still
laying low to the
vaccinations pop off what you doing
daddy oh i don't believe in the
vaccinations or the disease but yes
i am laying low
so and i'm not trying to look i'm not
trying to tell anybody what to do
that's just where i'm at with it so
that's fair that's your right yeah and
also i don't know anything and it is my
right so
i'm in tampa end of the month 26 27
tampa improv
come get some florida that's it man
thanks god baby smoke my natch fam hell
yeah
good luck taylor with him tit good
episode yeah taylor huh
sprout that [ __ ] yeah keep this post
on big titties sprout that body wallet
dog and send us a shot send us a jpeg
and maybe send us a before if you got
one yes and as a before and after
shirtless before and after or just three
whoppers out and mail them nuts in if
you get them d
you know deactivated yeah i'll dip them
in gold point around my neck don't yeah
dude that'd be crazy
dj nuts yeah we got yeah yeah we got his
nuts golded up hell yeah i'll be sick
i'll take them to coals and get them
[ __ ] dipped son
all right well i got nuts all around my
neck
brendan and theo fighter and weight i
got to go in and go hard in the paint
i do not think i am in flow black rifle
coffee i'm ready to go
i need a sponsor i am a monster about to
open up with this at my concerts flow is
contagious browser outrageous thicker
than girls that are instagram famous
damn
hungry like i'm fresh off keto seeing
red like andrew santino
every song i hit like the great bambino
brendan ate the queso and the quesoritos
but
everything's gonna be fine hate on me i
do not mind
theo looking like the type of dude they
got a pack of matches in his pockets at
all times
they sliding into my dms a couple of you
tribal couldn't beat them
quit playing like nintendo ds you don't
want to smoke like joey diaz
meaning y'all edible just got my
eyebrows threaded and i'm feeling
incredible
brendan's son hit me up he said it's too
loud in the club can you pick me up
[Music]
on a string